[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
foreign
day in our country
when someone who
entire life was built
on affirmative action Clarence Thomas
decides to ban affirmative action in
College college admissions
now my question is
to those of you out there who are
cheering this yay yay
yay now we don't have to give a fair
shake to people of color
in college admissions
when are we going to challenge legacy
admissions
do you understand that's why
one of the reasons why we have
affirmative action in the first place
is because countless institutions love
legacy admissions and I don't know if
you know I don't know if you know this
or not and you probably don't if you're
cheering this decision
that legacy admissions weren't designed
to get the brightest and the best
they weren't it's not designed to make
sure that there's a certain amount
of diversity it's actually the opposite
so I mean a lot of people are talking
today that institutions are going to get
whiter and more Asian
there's going to be less Latino
and less people of color
in some of the highest in the highest
regarded institutions that we have in
this country
and frankly it's it's a sad day
to that end
to think that the biggest and the
brightest out there the best out there
may not have a shot
at reaching their full potential and
serving us as a country a democracy and
a a collective of people
they may not have the opportunity
when they when they should
it's disgusting to be quite honest
it makes me sad
it pisses me off
But ultimately
it makes me question
rather
we value experience
and someone's life experience in this
country we have become so selfish
we don't understand
that the key to diversity is not it's
not skin color
the the key to diversity is not religion
it is the life experience
and who we are that we bring to the
table
everyone looks through the lens of life
through a different experience every
last one of us
and today the Supreme Court said that
your life experience
if you're one of the brightest in the
country
if alls it takes is one opportunity
that your experience
that your life
your unique diverse
lens that you look through
is discounted
it's only the widest
only the richest
that legacy admissions that matters the
most
and it's disappointing
in the greatest country on Earth
that we would decide
that our individual experiences
no matter what what part of the country
what state what city what county what
skin color what religion what family how
long you've been here
how long your family was here how you
got here
in this country
Equity equality and diversity should be
at the top of the list
It Is What Makes Us America
it is what makes us one of the strongest
if not the strongest democracy in the
world
in contrast
to the disappointing decision today
there is a woman
on the Supreme Court
a black woman katanji Brown Jackson
and it warms my heart that she's there
that is the future of America folks
that is the future of our democracy
katanji Brown Jackson is The Shining
Light On The Hill
and I think the lesson to be learned is
that the courts
are not
going to do Equity inequality they're
not we cannot rely on them to save us
from the scourge of fascism
from the slow chipping away
at our way of life
we can't count on them
we shouldn't ever count on them
no matter what the makeup of the court
is whether it's 6-3 a bunch of Nazis or
not
we cannot count on them we cannot count
on every single politician
to save us
to make sure that we have the
opportunity of the most equity and
equality that can be achieved in this
country
for everyone
if you're documented undocumented a
citizen a non-citizen
a person of color the lgbtq community
we have to do the work
and engage in our democracy and yes it's
going to take several decades to get the
stupid
back out of our discourse
you know I'm very transparent with you
because you are the best audience in the
world and I believe that the the longer
you listen and the more you pay
attention
the more you understand
politics and how important politics are
in this country
a lot of people don't want to predict I
don't like politics I don't want to talk
politics I don't like doing that
what do you think everything is
why do you think we have a nation
why do you think your children go to
public school in the morning
they get they get school lunch
how do you think the highways happen
how do you think you used your cell
phone this morning to get on Facebook
while you were making your children
breakfast
do you think that's just an accident
no it's not an accident
It Is Us
we are the people
we are the economy we are the market we
are the government It Is Us
it's not some weird
immaterial building somewhere
we are humans
all of us
and we're in this together
we're not always going to agree never
will we always agree on everything and
when we start to we need to question
ourselves we shouldn't agree on
everything
everyone's experience is different
that's why it's so important to have
diversity that's why it's so important
to gain as much equality and Equity that
you can in institutions
my experience is no more valuable than
yours and yours no valuable than mine
there is a certain Equitable amount of
diversity in this country that we can
achieve
we just have to stop getting in our our
own way
but they're not going to save us
the institutions
they're not going to save us
we must save them
you understand that right
I know I I use profanity profanity
poetry all the time and I salt and
pepper my commentary with a lot of curse
words
and I understand I might say things that
most people may not be willing to say
the way that I say them
there's a reason
that I do it
because of my life experience
this country needs more that look like
me that sound like me
the stand up
and to say enough is enough
of white supremacy
enough is enough of white supremacy with
its strong grasp on our institutions
whether it be colleges rather it be
whether it be government
rather it be corporations
we're not going to get rid of racism
any anyone who's experienced it if you
just listen to them for a half a second
and that's the problem is we don't
listen to other people's experience we
automatically think ours is superior
if you would listen
to their experience just open your ears
for a second you don't have to agree
with everything just listen to their
experience
and you'll understand
the importance
of diversity
you'll understand why it makes us strong
not weak
but together
as a people as a nation
as a democracy
we can save our institutions
and again I know it sounds weird but
they're not Gonna Save Us
our institutions are not designed to
save us
we are people We the People
institutions are just [__] we made up
and built over the last two centuries in
this country
and if we're not careful we will we will
watch them topple
and that's what the fascists want
that's what they want
they want to destroy the institutions
that we're trying
we the people are trying
to save
and maybe it's maybe it's the own the
libs attitude that makes them want to
kill these institutions how I listen to
them or video yesterday of Rhonda Santa
saying he wants to get rid of Commerce
at a Department of Education the IRS
whoosh
is there problems with our institutions
I mean this morning if you don't if you
don't see a better example the problem
with our institutions like the United
States Supreme Court
and why we are where we are
because because we the people drop the
ball
then you're not understanding that yeah
our institutions are [__] up no man
they're they're pretty [__] bad
but they're worth saving
they're worth it
it's worth every single inch every
single millimeter of work that we do in
our democracy
and is everyone going to come along for
the ride in this country no
it's America
that's one of the downfalls to Liberty
and freedom
is you have the liberty and freedom of
just running around as if ignorance is
bliss
especially
for white people
but
if you are paying attention which I know
our audience is and I know you
are engaging in your democracy to make
sure others are paying attention
you will understand
that the white folks
out there
who stand
as a beneficiary
of the institution of white supremacy in
this country regardless of if you like
it or don't like it you want it or you
don't want it
regardless if you believe in it or don't
believe in it
Your Privilege is there it is real
so much so that Clarence Thomas someone
who benefited from affirmative action
buys into white supremacy
and as a beneficiary of affirmative
action
he gives the payday
to white supremacy and white
institutions
it's pathetic
it's disgusting
it's horrendous
and that is why you have to pay
attention and get everyone you can to
pay attention and let them know that if
you have privilege use it to smash your
own privilege
a lot of folks don't like that I say
that
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty
and when you start
on the principle that you have the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people
you're not in the institution of Liberty
you're not
and if you're cheering if you're
cheering this decision today
not only are you not for Freedom or
Liberty
you are working against it
you can put Liberty in your name you can
put freedom in your name you can put
Patriot in your name
doesn't make you a fighter for those
things
it doesn't make you
a citizen
that believes in those things and those
institutions
don't kid ourselves
this is a fight
that it's not over
by a long shot
I know it's discouraging
this morning to hear this decision
but we as a people
we have more than enough opportunities
in front of us
to turn this country around
and make it a place of diversity Equity
equality inclusion
permanently
it won't be easy because democracy is
not easy it's not it's [__] hard
I keep telling you
being liberal
small L liberal
new liberal New Age liberal old liberal
classic liberal whatever the [__] you
want that whatever word you want to put
in front of it
liberalism with the small L rather
you're on the far left or an independent
who believes in democracy and you're
part of this Coalition hell you could be
on the right and believe in democracy
and be a liberal
liberalism is the foundation of strength
of our democracy
not the position of weakness weakness
folks would be letting one [__]
decide Our Fate
one one
dictator one authoritarian deciding
when how and what we're going to do and
who is going to do it
that would be the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people and that is not
Liberty
it's just not
we've got a lot of news today on top of
the Supreme Court decisions so don't go
anywhere don't touch that dial as they
say on radio we have a story there's a
breaking story uh just coming in
um it looks like it's from CNN broke
this story but Federal prosecutors have
arrested three investors that's right
three investors this morning on trading
charges related uh to the truth Social
Deal
yeah Gabe Sanchez is I think going to be
getting getting some collecting some
more information on this breaking news
uh CNN reporting I mean I do want to
tell you that CNN is reporting that as
of yet Donald Trump doesn't have
anything to do with this uh with this
insider trading I think I'm not sure
exactly what they're charging them with
yet
I'm not sure exactly what they're
charging
um but uh it looks like this Digital
World accusation acquisition Corporation
you remember the SPAC that they were
doing
um they secretly learned about some
information from who knows who and they
made some trading decisions uh and oh
man came away with a huge bank account
it's sort of the same thing I don't know
I'm not sure I haven't dug quite into it
yet but we will today we will today hear
live on the Tony Michaels podcast I got
a lot of Clips to show you Paul Ryan is
still out trying to convince the manga
base that they should leave
abandon Trump I can't believe this Paul
Ryan is the last person that's gonna
convince Maga
to abandon Trump like he's the last one
like I would probably convince I
honestly I would probably convince manga
to leave to abandon Trump long before
Paul Ryan could don't you think
am am I [__] crazy come on
that's the last person in the world
manga is gonna listen to when they're
saying you need to abandon Trump because
he's gonna lose like honestly I I really
think I really think the cultists would
believe me
long I'm on the list that they would
believe long before Paul Ryan would get
on that list right am I Am I Wrong Am I
Wrong in that can you check the facts on
that oh by the way we got raided again
on uh some kind of podcast thing
um I think it was yeah it was Edward
Edward Anderson who helps us tweet over
on our podcast account he sent it to me
the other day I showed you this uh oh
gosh it was back in February or
January something like that but it was
brought to my attention again so if I
get a chance I want to show that to you
today in the form of transparency
um here on the Tony Michaels podcast you
know I don't shy away from politicizing
any single issue
and I don't I don't shy away from any
kind of narrative or commentary no [__]
no we're not going to do that we're
going to tell the truth here we're going
to tell it just like we want it we're
going to use cathartic release to aim
our strategic outrage as we talked about
with Dr Rachel bidikoffer yesterday I am
so excited I was so excited to have her
back
weren't you what what a great time we
have when Doc is here
what a great time and she's tweeting
this morning about all these stories uh
so go go over there and and catch doc on
Twitter today
um I can't wait to I hope I hope we have
her on next week
I hope there's something there's always
something to talk to Dr Rachel
bittickoff for a bit but I hope we have
her on again next weekend so I hope you
enjoyed that yesterday don't forget to
subscribe here to the Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube and catch that
interview yesterday with Dr Rachel
bittickoff or you're not going to want
to miss a single episode we come to you
live every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
for two full hours two of them and
you're going to want to follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod
we'll have the bonehead of the week pole
going up over there tonight
bonehead of the week it's where you vote
you decide for the bone hint of the week
and on Friday which is tomorrow me and
Gabe Sanchez break down the bonehead of
the week in the second hour I also have
a big announcement for next week next
week is is a holiday week it's a holiday
weekend we will not have shows on Monday
Tuesday Wednesday we're going to take a
holiday we're going to take a quick
vacation and we'll be back next Thursday
so after tomorrow will be the last show
until next Thursday so you're not going
to want to miss tomorrow you're not
going to want to miss it I'm sure it'll
be a banger just like they all are here
on the Tony Michaels podcast and you can
watch it tomorrow you can watch it on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels just go to
facebook.com or your Facebook app and
search the Tony Michaels follow us there
don't forget to follow us on Facebook if
you're on Facebook a lot of people are
watching us right now on the Midas touch
Facebook page don't forget to go over
and follow us on my page
and a lot of people see us that
broadcast because they have a much
larger Facebook account than we do but
come over and follow us on Facebook if
you're listening on Facebook also I want
to thank everyone who follow us on
Twitch
twitch.tv slash the Tony Michaels
it's free to follow us on Twitch by the
way it doesn't cost you any money to
follow us on Twitch
but you can subscribe on Twitch here's a
free way to subscribe on Twitch if you
want a free way to subscribe it's weird
YouTube you subscribe and and that's
free on Twitch you follow and that's
free subscribe
might cost you money but if you have an
Amazon Prime account it doesn't cost you
a single nickel to subscribe it's really
cool actually it's a great way for you
to support us monetarily
without actually having to spend extra
money if you're an Amazon Prime account
holder
if you have a Prime account you can link
that Prime account with Amazon gaming to
your Twitch account and you can give us
the one free subscription that you get
with your Amazon Prime account each
month
and we get a couple bucks like literally
it's like two dollars and seven cents
if you give us that subscription using
your Amazon Prime account so here's what
you do you go to the Tony michaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com the
directions are the fourth one down it
says link Amazon and Prime you click
that it's all the directions it also
gives the directions now how to
resubscribe
to the Tony Michaels podcast over on
Twitch because to get the money each
month from Prime you gotta work for it
they're not going to give it to us for
free for nothing right you got to do a
little bit
so the directions over there how to
resubscribe so don't forget that if
you've already subscribed once get in
there re-subscribe every month to make
sure that your Amazon subscription for
Amazon gaming on Twitch goes to us every
single month at the Tony Michaels
podcast go to thetonymichaels.com the
see tonymichaels.com check it out there
one last thing before we go to break I
want to tell you we have all the pride
merch in the store and there is a promo
code why just for the next couple days
if you want to get 15 off your pride
merch your [__] Pride merch go to
store.d Tony michaels.com that
store.thetonymichaels.com use the promo
code Pride that's promo code Pride for
15 off your pride package over there or
anything really anything you want in the
store it's 15 off thank you for
participating I I'm so excited that you
guys encourage us to do the pride logo
of Miss loveseat had the idea and then
everyone jumped on like yep that's what
we want so we gave Sanchez did that
design he put it in there it's a great
design so go check it out at
store.thetonymichaels.com any purchase
that you make right now until the end of
June 15 off just use the promo code
Pride that's promo code Pride at
store.the Tony michaels.com we always
appreciate your support don't go
anywhere we're gonna be right back right
after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you've
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with these
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
God damn it's hot my ears are sweating
underneath these headphones good Lord
no is it hot where you're at the air
conditioning is on [__] full blast
here
holy moly not a drop of water either
yesterday right before the show it
started raining here where I'm at
and I thought oh yeah it's raining and
it's like
it rained for like two minutes barely
got the ground wet
Christ
whoo I had to take my headphones off on
the break whoa
so Gabe Sanchez is going to join us at
the top of the hour he's a little busy
he's his hands are tied so he's gonna
join us at the top of the other so you
know what I want to do uh I wasn't able
to do a uh a patreon thing last week I
just I I need some reprieve and we're
gonna have a vacation this week so let's
do this what's let's let's uh play a
game here we're gonna do uh
shoot the [__] if you guys aren't aware
shoot this [__] is where you asked a
question in the chat so whether you're
on Twitch Facebook or YouTube whether
you're on our YouTube channel or the up
wires YouTube channel go ahead and put a
question in the chat that's right you
can put a question in the chat I'll
answer it here's what happens on patreon
I do I do a little thing called ask me
anything it's 30 minutes long it
normally goes longer I don't know I like
the talking stuff did you figure that
out so it's about 30 minutes long
and you get to ask any question you want
you get to ask any single question you
want and I'll answer it and you can ask
you can ask people who've been in there
the patreon members you can ask them
I'll answer any any question that you
have as long as it's within that 30
minutes
you know within that 30 minutes I'll
answer any question that you have in the
live chat but right now we're going to
do we call it shoot the [__] here on the
show because I get to pick and choose
the ones that I wanna
answer so if you have a question it
doesn't matter if it has to do with
politics it doesn't have to it can be
anything
because I can skip over it during the
show during shoot the [__] but ask me
anything's really cool so go to
patreon.com the Tony Michaels or go to
the Tony michaels.com check out the
patreon page there I think today I think
today we'll do an ask me anything
um once I'm ramping up the show and
getting edits and getting it posted I'll
probably do an ask me anything today for
30 minutes so if you're on patreon if
you are a patreon member don't forget
we'll probably do an ask me anything
later on in the afternoon after the show
is over when I'm still working on
getting the show posted on like apple
Spotify Google all the the audio version
because that's what happens is like I do
the show and then and then I gotta edit
it and then I gotta upload it to all the
podcast directories so you guys can go
download it because that's important you
should be downloading the audio version
it helps us out here at the show someone
asked the other day why why if we watch
it why should we download the audio
version it helps us out number one but
number two you want to make sure that
you set if you have a directory on your
on your phone
you want to make sure it sets to where
it automatically downloads that way if
you miss the show or can't watch the
show or if you're in the car or
something that's easy to go ahead and
listen to it later on if you need to or
if you missed part of the show let's say
you only were here for 30 minutes you
can get that get the app get the
directory download each and every show
that way you have the shows available to
go ahead and listen to them when you
need to but go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels we'll do an ask me anything
while I'm posting the audio version of
today's show on the directories
um so you'll see me working and I'll be
answering questions in the chat so if
you got a question right now go ahead
and put it in the chat and we'll shoot
the [__] I'll show you kind of what what
ask me anything it's kind of like
um
let's see Amy ask your Tony did you see
what is left of the imploded but but
like can
what what Bud Light can are you talking
about the boycott on Bud Light listen
there
[Music]
they keep posting videos so there's like
a parade a bright parade I think it was
in Canada and Bud Light had a sponsored
float like here's a big [__] sign
that said Bud Light on this pride parade
and they were posted like oh my God Bud
light's doubling down I'm like yeah your
boycott didn't work and then they'll
they'll tweet at me they're like oh
Scott Price oh sales numbers I'm like
people are dumb as dog [__] you were so
stupid
Bud Light is one brand that
Anheuser-Busch owns you [__] fools
like a Michelob Ultra and like in real
life in real life you'll go in a bar and
you'll it's you're on counter one of
these [__] idiots who think if they
drink Bud Light it's gonna turn them gay
or some [__] I don't know what they
think it's [__] weird don't come at
me about it it's it's their [__]
weird obsession
with the trans people or something I'm
not really sure why they think Bud Light
makes you gay I can't figure that out I
really can't I'm not sure they don't
really say they're just like we don't
like it because hmm we're we're we we
don't like them kinds of people because
we're scared of women who who might have
a penis they're not mad at trans men you
notice that right ah man a trans man oh
man if there was commercials with trans
men with beards and muscles and flannel
shirts
you know like splitting wood
throwing hay bales and drinking Bud
Light they wouldn't give a [__] they
wouldn't give a [__] man not a [__]
would they give but oh my God you you
showed me a trans woman and it makes me
horny and then you couple that with a
trans woman taking money to promote Bud
Light like anyone else would
ah and they're losing so the CEO of Bud
Light or Anheuser Bush excuse me
uh goes on I think it was CBS This
Morning I think it's what it was an
interview that he did and they're asking
him about this and they were like uh
aren't you kind of playing to both sides
and he's like yeah kinda I mean yeah I
mean we we've been supporters of the
lgbtq community for over 20 years
because they um they they drink beer see
see uh gay people trans people drink
beer it's kind of our business to sell
people beer their people they like to
drink beer so we kind of sell it to them
you know what I mean we Market it to
them too so they'll buy it it's called
capitalism you [__] idiots but these
boneheads are all pissed off because oh
my God Anheuser-Busch is doubling down
so we're gonna double down on our
boycott we're gonna destroy Bud Light
listen if you haven't destroyed Bud
Light already with this amount of fake
ass outrage that you have then you're
not doing it correctly I hope that helps
I don't know what that is your question
Amy but
there you go
[Music]
um let's see oh someone says um
how hot is it where Jim Jordan is
sitting Richard answers how hot is it
where Jim Jordan it's in Jim I don't
report sex time Jordan listen there was
a Supreme Court decision saying that yes
the folks in the Ohio State wrestling uh
molestation Scandal can
get Discovery and I can't wait I can't
wait if Jim Jordan is deposed in that
case can you oh man that would be a
shame that would be a shame if it
destroyed that [__] it really
would oh man I would hate to see Jim
Jordan's reputation just absolutely
trash as a pile of [__] garbage that
we know he is hmm that would really suck
that'd be horrible wouldn't it
um Mason asked here uh hey Tony which
Republicans do you think will be uh
vacationing in Russia for the Fourth of
July I mean I think they all cancel
their flights I don't know if you know
what's going on in Russia but they're
like
because they don't know who to pick
Putin or pregosian literally look Putin
is such a [__] [__] right he's a
he's a murderous [__] dictator
as far as I'm concerned
pagosian would not be any [__] better
frankly pergosian actually has his
faculties more about him and is way way
way way more steep than some evil
[__] [__] that guy is a scary
[__] I don't think it's good for
the world for either one of them son of
a [__] to be in charge of Russia okay
now short term short term I think all
this is good for the world in that there
is a clear weakness and instability
and Russia there has been for a long
time it's just it's now the world is
starting to really see it and this March
for other Wagner group to Moscow even
when they turned back we're not really
sure what happened there was a deal made
with Belarus
um um the president of Belarus and Putin
and progosian the the leader of Wagner
which I mean Putin made this nightmare
of his own and that's why I'm saying
that Russia has this weakness but I
would bet I would bet they cancel Mason
and I bet they'd cancel their flights
but they're kind of disappointed you
know what I mean like you know when you
have a really exciting party planned and
then you just can't have the party
you're like God damn I really wanted to
go barbecue hot dogs and hamburgers
with with my vladdy daddy right Vladimir
Putin they're vladi Dottie
I don't think it's gonna happen though
they probably I don't know if they had I
don't know if they had Insurance on
their flights or not you know like the
refundable
I don't know maybe it's non-revunnable
[Music]
um
[Laughter]
let's see
oh someone's asking about the uh uh
the submersive and Brandon Lewis here
says uh the first question was on the
submers it the the submarine apparently
there's pictures of it uh of them of the
records they pulled the wreckage
out from the Bottom of the Sea and um
there's not much left of the [__]
thing apparently they're trying to
investigate what happened well what
happened was is that
um
you let a bunch of Rich dummies
do a bunch of Rich dumb things and
that's what happened and that's the
result it's really not complicated to
understand what happened here it's
really not I just wish I just wish Elon
would make his own submersible you know
what I mean make his own submarine right
I I I'm really rooting for that Elon go
prove that you're better at it that's
what you should do my friend that's what
you should do
Joanna ask her do you think Jack Smith
should take up
ivana's casket I'm not saying he should
or he shouldn't personally but
um if they can't find those documents at
betminster hmm they they may they may or
just may not be
in a certain box that was buried in the
ground I mean a lot of people have this
speculation and the reason why is
because she was cremated right
now I don't know if you've ever
experienced like the amount of Ashes
that you get back from a cremation
um
but it's not a lot
right it's not a lot of Ashes and it was
a full-size casket at the funeral like
big [__] human sized casket
and they throw in you know a pile of
Ashes that would fill up a a Saltine
cracker box
right you know what I'm saying that's
about that's about right isn't it right
right I don't know
and they and they had like 13 people
carrying that casket
that had that
one one smidge of ashes in it seems kind
of suspicious to me and then he buries
it on his private property
he's like I'm gonna put it there so no
one [__] with it
you think you just burn the
[__] though don't you don't you
think you just burned them
I mean he flushed him down a toilet he
was eating the [__] right
I mean that's a story that's a story
that we get
I don't know I don't know I don't know
if they'll dig it up but maybe they
should
well let's see what else do we get
let's see
what else do we got
oh someone's
am I did I get the question wrong about
the Bud Light thing
is that what everyone's wondering
someone keeps saying no no no no you got
you're getting mixed up Tony you're not
understanding what we're saying in the
chat and that's probably possibly true
because here's what happens I get all of
the chats so I see well all the Twitter
so if you're on Twitter like sending
messages I can't see that [__]
that's elon's problem not mine yeah I
mean what do you want me to do what the
[__] am I supposed to do
Twitter then Periscope are [__]
horrible they just don't work with the
[__]
so I can't see your messages if you're
sending them through Twitter really the
only reason why I broadcast to Twitter
anymore is just to put the link on there
so you can see the line broadcaster when
you're like scrolling through your feed
you're like ah Tony's [__] yelling
and screaming into the microphone about
something and then you can actually
click on the link and go watch it
on YouTube or you can click on the other
link and go to like twitch or whatever
no one watches on [__] Twitter No One
and I get this a lot the trolls like oh
you have five people watching I'm like
yeah on Twitter dummy because they're
smart enough not to watch this [__] on
Twitter because Periscope is [__]
garbage because Elon won't fix it
I mean Hey listen I actually I I I would
do a meeting with Elon I know that
sounds crazy but I would do a meeting
with Elon and let him know exactly what
he should and shouldn't do with
Periscope and broadcasting [__] on
Twitter like Twitter spaces and like
Tucker Carlson stupid [__] like hey look
man if you really want to compete in the
media space you need to trash all of
that you need to trash all that and
start from scratch
a building an app that will handle the
media that you want to handle in in long
form because Twitter isn't designed to
handle long form content I don't know if
you know that like even the Twitter
spaces sometimes last for [__] ever
right they're they're long form in that
they're more than two two and a half
minutes
but I mean even that it it wasn't
designed originally to record they had
to add that feature and even still the
recording feature is kind of [__]
like you can't list it anywhere right I
mean you could put them in a thread or
something
but there's no like the person or the
account that has the [__] lives
there's no tab that shows their entire
lives in a timeline are searchable like
that
to find the recording to listen to it
there's no programming guide for Twitter
spaces it's [__] [__] it's [__] it's
[__] garbage
I mean listen
we've had radio for a long time
a long it's it's been a it's it's an
older technology that radio stuff
and that's all that's all Twitter spaces
is and they want to act like it's some
kind of great thing that you oh well you
can bring people up on stage the [__]
are you talking about have you did you
listen to the radio in the 80s and 90s
they gave you a [__] number you
called in and talked to them what are
you talking about yeah but you can get
eight people to to talk
so you can do that on a radio too it's
not hard you just conference call it all
in and they can yell and scream at each
other this isn't new technology you're
just putting radio on a on a [__] app
on your phone
that's all you're doing and half the
time it doesn't work where the [__] and
you can't find it you can't find it
there's no programming guide for the
Twitter spaces none none that's not
that's not long form media Elon that's
just people on Twitter talking to each
other really is all it is on the radio
man
what the hell was I talking about
anyways
went up on a tangent there oh yes
broadcasting chatting I have a lot of
that's right a lot of see how I get off
drink a lot of chats that come in I
don't know yesterday drank a little bit
it's it was Wednesday it was karaoke
night what do you want for me I may have
had a few Jagermeister shots what are
you gonna do
what are you gonna do
uh Deb asks do I have pets yes we have a
we have a dog we have a dog uh usually
he's sitting on the chair next to me but
he's not this morning he must be
somewhere else he's just sitting right
here but I grew up on a farm so I grew
up with a lot of animals
like that's that's all we had we had
chickens cattle we had cats we had dogs
no Goats No Hogs now we may we mainly
did cattle it's mainly beef cattle is
what we had
um but uh we we would do a lot of bottle
calves we had a lot of chickens and so
we eat a lot of farm fresh eggs that
sort of thing so uh so I I grew up with
animals everywhere so I'm not it's not
that I I don't love animals or like
animals I just I grew up that way and we
had animals everywhere so it's not my
desire to live in a zoo
I don't know I kind of felt like I lived
in the zoo when I was a kid so
maybe I'll maybe I'll desire it some
other day you know when I get older but
I just um I don't have the desire to
have a zoo around me some people love
animals and they love having a lot of
animals there's nothing wrong with it
nothing wrong with it we again when I
was a kid we had animals everywhere they
were I mean sometimes we'd bring bottle
calves in that were struggling to
survive we'd bring them in on our back
porch like we're our laundry machine and
[__] was
we'd set up like a little kiddie pool
and we'd have to we'd have to feed them
electrolytes and stuff so I've had a lot
of pets pets in my life and been around
a lot of animals so but yes we have a
dog we have a dog what is George Santos
up to uh probably lying
Karma asked what is George Santos up to
I probably probably lying that's
probably what he's doing today it's a
pretty easy one pretty easy question to
get out there we got a few more minutes
left here before the top of the hour
we'll probably take a break and then
we'll come back now because we have some
news we got to get to but I want to
shoot the [__] with you guys
um
what else do we get what other questions
do we get here if you got a question
sticking in the chat they're going to
try to get to a couple more
gonna try to get to a couple more
questions
um
MB asks how many diapers has Trump gone
through this week well he's he's
[__] a lot of bricks and this week
and last week and probably next week
it's not going to get fun for him uh
Rudy Giuliani apparently has done a
federal proffer with a special counsel
and prosecutors in the January 6 case
now if you don't know what a proper is
it's not immunity a proper is not
immunity it just gives you the ability
to go in and tell them [__]
that that they already know that you can
confirm for them it doesn't give you
immunity from prosecution though of the
[__] that you say
so and self-incriminating so he would
sit there with his lawyer lawyers and
give a proper now Rudy Giuliani being
the former United States Attorney of the
southern district of New York in the
late 80s early 90s Rudy Giuliani knows a
lot about proffers like he would have
done a [__] ton of I mean him and his
him and his uh attorneys in his office
at the sdny would have done a ton of
proffers with people who they wanted to
prosecute or were indicted
so and you can give a proper whether
you're indicted or you're not indicted
right
so if you're the target of Investigation
which that's the thing that this makes
me assume I'm no [__] lawyer here I'm
the lawyer here
okay but I have I have experience with
proffers
and the federal court and federal
prosecutors breathing down your [__]
neck but here's the thing is that what
this indicates to me
um and what I would say my commentary on
this for Rudy and the reason why it
would make Trump [__] his diaper here is
because Rudy along with Mark Meadows uh
Mike Flynn Sydney Powell to Mike pillow
gang which is weird the Overstock CEO I
can't believe these people are [__]
characters in this story right uh Jenna
Ellis the white house uh Council as well
uh along with John Eastman and Jeffrey
Clark these these characters in this
story are very crucial
um in in making sure that Jack Smith has
all the information he has to prove that
yes Donald Trump knew that the election
was being stolen by him
and he was trying to steal it
right like that's what Jackson is trying
to prove here in the January 6 case not
that Donald Trump knew he lost that I
mean I mean yeah he's got to prove that
to some degree right but he's got to
prove that there was motive there was
motive
an intention behind obstructing official
proceeding
um and that's what he's doing with Rudy
Jeffrey Clark John Eastman again all
these characters and Rudy Giuliani would
have been really close to Trump knowing
that stuff because Rue Giuliani was a
foot soldier in the effort to overturn
the 2020 election to make sure Donald
Trump remained dictator in King of the
United States
so
when Rudy Giuliani is going going to do
a proper he's not receiving immunity
necessarily but what he is doing is he's
giving prosecutors information that
could incriminate someone else
it could incriminate someone else it
doesn't mean that he's got the goods it
just means that he may have the goods
and the federal prosecutors are willing
to listen to him since he's a Target or
indicted which is really Julian Rudy
Giuliani as far as we know is not
indicted
there is no open uh public indictment
from the grand jury
I mean there could be one possibly under
seal that we don't the public does not
know about I don't know that that's the
case or not but it it does give me uh
thought that Rudy Giuliani definitely is
a target of indictments in the January 6
case and let me tell you something if
Rudy Giuliani
is a target indictments in the January
Case by the grand jury and Jack Smith
there's a lot of other [__] and
him going in and giving a proper is not
good for Trump so yeah he's probably
he's probably filling up diapers I would
imagine
what else do we get any other question
we got ah we got time for maybe one more
question depends on how long I talk
about it
oh did you notice that again
talk a lot
let's see what else do we have that's an
Eastman question and I want to get into
the Eastman thing too much more uh uh
how long oh here here we go here's one
about the show uh Margie says how long
does it take you to prepare for the show
hopefully he sees this now have you been
trying to ask this one for a while or is
people trying to ask this one so I
prepare I I am constantly preparing for
the show what I mean by that is I'm
always watching the news I'm always
keeping up with the stories and I'm
trying to determine what's important to
the National narrative and what isn't
right so I'm constantly doing that like
this morning when I woke up and I saw
the Supreme Court decision
um I wasn't necessarily excited about
this as as far as
um happened to do commentary on because
such a it's such a miserable [__]
story
and I I try to provide I try to provide
commentary here that gives you cathartic
release right so an aim of your
strategic outrage right we say that all
the time here because I want I want you
to ultimately listen to the show of
course I want you to be entertained but
I also want it to encourage you to
engage in your democracy not just listen
to the show that's the thing that the
right wing knows that the left wing
really sucks at the left is horrible at
this they're [__] horrible and I
don't want to name names or point
fingers because I'd piss off some of my
good friends here but they're [__]
shitty at this stuff they come on and
they'll pile you with facts and data and
they'll do all this stuff and oh man oh
man you know look at look at us we're
Elite and we're telling you that that
we're Elite they're not having a
conversation with you the right wing has
understood this for decades and decades
one of the first to really understand
this and to to put it in demotion deploy
it was Rush Limbaugh Rush Limbaugh would
have a conversation with his viewers uh
every single day for three hours
and it was a conversation when you
listen to Rush whether you agreed with
him or disagree with him which I did on
99.9999 100 I vehemently disagree with
Rush Limbaugh on almost every [__]
issue and every [__] thing he said
but he was having a conversation with
folks right when you listen to Rush it's
not like he was talking to you
right like you're at a kitchen table not
not not a teacher talking to you and and
telling you
you know facts data and reading from a
textbook
that's what the left does that's what
the left does a lot and it's [__]
annoying as [__] it's not entertaining
it's it's just there to pump your head
full of facts because they think you're
gonna go out in the world and you're
gonna just puke up their facts right
that's not how it works design how it
works not how it works do you know do
you know what people do tell people that
they know and they see they tell them
about their um oh it's like their
feelings their emotions their beliefs
right that's what they talk about that's
how you communicate as a what is it
called human being oh yeah oh yeah oh
that's kind of funny how that works so
the left is horrible at this and they
don't understand it like man we're
giving these people all the facts they
need we're giving them all the data that
they need to make a rational decision
yeah but you're not giving them the
emotion
you're not telling them how the [__]
they should feel about this
what the [__] does the facts matter you
think people give a [__] about the facts
get the [__] out of here right left
Center independent socialist fascist
Communists whatever the [__] you are
if you think every single one of these
people are making decisions based on the
facts as they see it you're a stupid
idiot you're a dumb [__] and
you're starting off on the wrong foot
that's why I put this show together the
way I put it together
that's why I do it the way I do it I
don't ride out and script every [__]
thing I say I don't even have an outline
of [__] I'm gonna talk about I used to
do that and it was horrible I used to
have tried to have an outline back when
we did it once a week and it was like 30
minutes or an hour it's horrible
I was like I just I just need to talk
about this [__]
they understand what the [__] I'm saying
they understand the emotion the feeling
behind it they get it I understand
government I understand our democracy I
get the elections I know how the the
parties work how the system works I get
all that
I know the facts
so just go out and talk to people just
talk to them talk to them not Adam not
over them not trying to [__] be you
know professor
no so what I try to do is I try to stay
up to speed that's where I have to take
my break sometimes is I gotta take my
breaks from the news and social media so
you'll notice like at night I'm usually
not tweeting as much on the weekend I
normally don't tweet as much and I'm
trying to stay up with the news as I go
along but I'm trying not to engage as
much just because I I don't want to get
bogged down into constantly being
prepared so my preparation for the show
is just to know
is just to know I'm really good at
talking I don't know if you noticed and
I'm really good at creating content on
the Fly
it's what I do but
um in the mornings as far as actual
preparation for each and individual show
it takes about an hour
I usually um
I usually text Gabe
um I uh there's a person and I don't
know if they want me to say their name
if they do I I'm not scared to say it
but I just haven't discussed that with
but this this person helps write some
stuff for us in the mornings so I
notified them and I'm like hey this is
going to be our lead story so Gabe
Sanchez will start making the art we'll
start talking back and forth about what
the thumbnail is going to be sometimes
it's very quick sometimes we have to
jump around from story to story decide
which one we're gonna do and then we get
the person to write up the little uh do
a little write-up on it
and they help us do that that's because
I'm terrible at writing horrible at it
if you see my personal Twitter account
you'll know because I don't delete
tweets I can go in there and see all the
[__] spelling errors and all the
yours that are supposed to be you ours
yeah I do that [__] you
I I do all kinds of crazy [__] over
there on Twitter that you that the
grammar police would be really upset
about
but I don't care that's just me that's
how I'm gonna do it that's me being
authentic I don't delete tweets because
I spelled something wrong I just don't
do it
but that's why I make sure someone helps
right
because I'm not very good at it but but
then we we put together the description
I go in and I set the show to air
um in our software that you're seeing it
through right now that's what helps me
pull up your comment here on Facebook
and so I set it through there and it
goes out and I tweet some stuff I post
up on uh Mastodon I post stuff on
Facebook and I post stuff on patreon so
everyone knows the show and then I I
just I just go live usually my first
line like my intro as the music is
rolling
I'm deciding when I'm gonna say in that
moment
I used to try to have what I'm gonna say
be real clever about it hours before
what it's gonna be but I discovered it
makes it not authentic enough so I just
I try not to prep each word too much
that's what I try not to do so I
appreciate the question I'm glad that
you guys are interested in how this show
comes to life because you are part of
the show and that's the purpose that's
the whole idea is you guys are part of
the show here on the Tony Michaels
podcast we sit here we got the best
moderators in the world I don't know if
you noticed that
I gotta say that we have some of the
best moderators in the world
and and you guys should be so
appreciative of them because they keep
the chat going they keep it up to speed
they keep you guys in in there and
having the conversation it really is
when they call it the [__] fam it
really is a family
there's been there's people in there and
I don't know if MJ's here today or not
but MJ will attest to this she's an OG
like MJ was here the moderator MJ was
here like
we had like five people listening
fine people listening and I was one of
them watching
on a screen
and she'll tell you that we've talked to
each other that we've had each other
around this whole time and if you're
just joining the [__] family you're
going to discover this that there's just
not the show it's just not about the
show exactly I mean yeah you come here
to watch and listen but it's also about
conversating with people in the chat and
we're not scared to let trolls be around
we're not scared to let people with the
little different opinions stick around
yeah we don't give a [__] that's fine I
want you to listen I want you to listen
so everyone give some love to the mods
of the best moderators in the [__]
world don't go anywhere I'm gonna see if
I can get Gabe Sanchez coming up here
now don't go anywhere we're gonna take a
quick break we'll be right back
right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
thank you
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're
to the Tony Michaels podcast
Jay says
she was here
episode 38. I guess I guess she
remembers the uh the exact episode
episode number 38. we're on 427 God damn
MJ
she's probably listened to me than any
other person yeah it's in the jet holy
[__]
that's a lot that's a lot of my mouth
well my something must be right if MJ
hasn't skipped out yet something's got
to be right right Am I Wrong come on
it's great and I'm glad to have all of
you here rather rather you're from Midas
Touch whether you're sparklers uh rather
your Ty tea lovers hey come in and have
some fun
oh boy I love every single one of you
and rather you love me or you love to
hate me I love you back for sure for
sure I love you back and I'm glad to
have all of you here I'm glad to have
all your we're trying I'm trying to get
Gabe Sanchez
um here on the on the show he's got a
few things he's ramping up this morning
so we're gonna try to
um go go forward
without
the guy with the last name Sanchez
there might be a new saga uh in the um
small rant over on Twitter he's got a
YouTube account too you guys should go
follows YouTube I posted it on Twitter
let's see if I can find it here there's
a there's a YouTube video he's he's
clipping up the show you know a lot of
people get mad about that you're like
wow you're clipping my show and putting
it on your YouTube channel small rank
keep going I don't give a [__] I'm not
gonna copyright you cut it up clip it
whatever you want to do go put it over
there man have fun with it
um he's got a new a new song out too and
you know he did the uh
that fella named the last name Sanchez
and then the uh the remix also
and that's what the clip about here it
is here it is on my timeline I put it
here it said thanks for the clip
small rat
Sanchez guys remix here I'll retweet it
again there you go
that way you see it
a lot of times when you put like a
YouTube link and it's just a YouTube
link with a few words
the out that Twitter algorithm doesn't
like that anymore because they're like
whoa are you trying to get people off
our platform
so they'll [__] leave
have you noticed that too Gabe Sanchez
goddamn time
Gabe Sanchez is here everybody out there
waiting for you I was doing shoot this
[__] and I told him that I was trying to
get you on and yeah they said Sanchez
tying there asking if you were gonna
come on today oh yeah yeah yeah I'm I'm
obviously coming on the show I had get
your mic you need to get your kind of
things I had things to do sorry man you
know I'm still rearranging the room and
the setup on the table here yeah anyway
you were sending me pictures of the new
setup you want for um what was that yeah
yeah and it was funny because he was
sending me pictures and he was all in
different outfits I'm like look the
backgrounds look good but these outfits
look like [__] man you need to get you
need to get with the opposite did you
get the ones where I wasn't wearing
enough well the nudes yeah I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna divulge the nudes that
you're into the audience yeah I mean you
know that's how it goes yeah yeah yeah
well how's everyone doing ah they're
doing great they're doing great this
morning they're a little upset about the
Supreme Court decision yeah rightfully
soon rightfully so but I think they're
excited about the three people that were
arrested in the the the Trump the Trump
uh spat deal did you read into that at
all were you did you get a chance I got
a I got a a chance to read a little bit
into who are these [__] getting
arrested I didn't really say
I just said that they had
self-surrendered
um to prosecutors to the to the
courthouse to the U.S Marshals
apparently on these charges uh it seems
like insider trading charges it really
didn't say yeah I mean it sounds like
they Together made more than 22 million
dollars but this is all the way back in
October 2021 so this is almost three
years ago
by illegally trading on public two years
yeah sorry two years ago God damn yeah I
don't know don't skip ahead feels like
three but really is two right how do you
keep track but yeah they they they uh
insider trading man crazy the defendants
allegedly tipped off friends and
colleagues who also purchased Securities
in the digital world before the blank
check firms uh Trump media deal became
even public so uh the indictment or
Michael
schwartzmann Gerald Sportsman and Bruce
garelick who served as director are
those German names why are these I don't
know I mean just seems weird doesn't it
it could be Germans yeah
um
but uh it looks like Bruce Garrett
there's no significance in that it just
sounded like that to me I don't know
yeah I don't know
I got a little German in me I mean I got
a little German in me as well uh
it sounds like the last guy Bruce
garelick is uh served as the Director of
the digital world's board of directors
at home I'm curious about something uh
who
who came up with
is this are you talking about the SPAC
deal yeah yeah is that what you're
trying to do
because this this is this is interesting
it's really complicated right because
the the story from CNN this morning is
they they were sure to put in the very
bottom of the story they're like uh
Donald Trump has not been implicated in
this scheme at all yet and now I want to
emphasize the word yet because there is
insider trading and normally when you
have insider trading it's normally
someone who knows a lot about it who
gives the information to inside trade to
these people do you remember the Martha
Stewart
um case of insider trading uh a little
bit yeah yeah so I I read James comey's
book the FBI director that yeah uh fired
because yeah he wanted loyalty right
exactly so I read his book and did you
know that uh James Comey prosecuted
Martha Stewart did you know that no I
didn't know that yeah so if you go read
his book and that's part of the book
that actually gives you a little bit of
insight of who James Comey is and why
that idiot made some of the stupid
decisions he made in 2016 but
and that's neither here nor there but he
talks about in there where he's trying
to determine whether he wants to
prosecute Martha Stewart or not and he's
like well she's really famous she's
really rich she's really white right
she's really white really white like
especially when she's standing next to
Snoop Dogg white like what she's usually
standing next to Snoop yeah do you think
they bang I don't think they bang but I
don't know
really good friends Snoop is married so
right right right I don't think I don't
know but I'm not I'm not making anything
I wonder who knows she was a Sports
Illustrated model now so right yeah well
she's pretty smoking hot but here's the
thing is Martha Stewart they were trying
James Comey at the time he was the
United States Attorney he was trying to
determine whether he should or shouldn't
make a big huge media [__] show out of
the problem I mean holding people
accountable right right right that's
kind of funny but he decided to go ahead
and hold her accountable yeah Insider
true yeah I mean she also got a
you know house arrest so that's that was
totally fair well no she went to prison
yeah I know but like did she really
serve the time that she needed to when
she was in prison what do you mean she
didn't serve enough time is what you're
saying I don't know how many years did
she serve let's see ah well I mean she I
think she did like eight months in a
federal prison camp I think the way she
didn't I think is the time let's see
let's see I mean listen
I know people talk about federal prison
camps as if they're Camp feds but it
five months five months okay five not
eight months yeah you're charging
convicted of a number of things
let me tell you something Mr Gibbs in
prison five months and eight months is
the same [__] thing in prison and and
who will tell you that or is the people
who are sentenced like 18 years 20 years
you're like [__] you you [__] yeah
yeah five months two years she spent uh
yeah yeah well well she was
uh I mean because there's there's paper
there's your probation because there's
no parole in the federal system two
years of probation uh yeah okay
sorry five-month prison yeah five-month
house arrest two-year probation right
that's what it was and that's probably
what the Bop dictated for because they
probably gave her a year or something
like that I don't know and she got good
time year and a day she got good times
anyways I mean she was when she left
that prison that [__] was so impeccably
designed someone's saying hard times she
didn't do hard time no but but
to Martha Stewart it probably was really
hard time oh yeah yeah oh [__] yeah
there's not a lot of conveniences even
in a federal prison camp like there's
just it's not as cushy as you think it
is right like you watch the movies and
[__] it's not that I mean they're nice
most of like the the federal prison
camps in this country uh the one in
Colorado uh the that Rod Blagojevich you
know him I know Rod man yeah rod rod was
um that that one is an old hotel like it
used to be a hotel and then you have a
fence around it or nothing you wouldn't
even know it's a [__] prison if there
wasn't a sign in front of it that said
Bureau of Prisons you know federal
prison camp no I'm serious you wouldn't
[__] know like at a distance it just
looks like a [__] hotel there's a big
huge deck on the back of it because it
used to be a [__] hotel yeah yeah and
it like overlooks the mountains it's
[__] beautiful it's [__] beautiful
so I mean there is that amenity because
it's they're inside like old college
campuses
um one in South Dakota is uh it's an old
college campus like the one at
Leavenworth the one um in um uh in
Indiana there's another there's a couple
others they're they're kind of the same
they built those back in like the 60s
they're actual prisons they got fences
around them yeah yeah but the door's
unlocked so this idea that these prison
camps or cushy isn't all that right so
so these guys that got arrested these
three guys who are they
so the the three the three people are
Michael schwarzen no no I mean what what
who where were they at in the insider
trading scheme oh so it says uh
does it say who they were communicating
with and who they how they know I mean
they had they lay out some sort of yeah
two years after being announced the
murder is yet to be completed
indictments say the defense passed on
digital worlds confidential information
to friends on a trip to Las Vegas to
Michael schwartzman's neighbors and to
Gerald Sportsman's employees at a
Furniture Supply Company all together
those contacts purchased tens of
thousands of Securities uh Securities
ahead of the murder announced according
to the indictment the three div three
defendants were indicted to or sorry
were invited to invest in digital world
as well as special
purpose or another special purpose so
they were
they got invited to invest in that's
back and then they got invited into
invest in another well yeah if you're
gonna cry on that crime all the way [__]
uh David here on Facebook says stop it
Tony now I want to go now
again
and again might be a beautiful view but
it's a shitty seat okay it's not a
comfortable seat rather than adhere to
his duty as an Insider we allege that
garelick who is this this director
together with the Schwartzman monetize
that information to generate over 20
million dollars in illicit profits
uh according to uh Gerber gruel I could
be butchering the name but director of
the sec's division of enforcement said
in a statement the case demonstrates
that the sec's ongoing commitment to
exposing insider trading whenever it
occurs including inspack murders and
remember this yeah this is
going I'm sure I'm sure that when
they're like look you guys profited 20
million dollars let's just run through
the list of the amount of people that
you told and the crimes that you
committed because each person obviously
is you know probably another count to it
um and the actions they took and then
from that point they're like okay how do
you want to play this do you want to
give up other people
or do you just want to take the fall
so you know uh like we said there's
probably The Insider information is
probably coming from someone that
directed you know someone like garelick
to do it if he's the director of the
board
uh of digital world's board of directors
that you would probably think and I'm
pretty sure wasn't wasn't Donald Trump a
director and then he removed himself
there was a few of them that removed
themselves before this investigation uh
David had another question here on
Facebook he said do they have conjugal
visits I'm assuming you're talking about
federal federal prisons do not have you
actually during your visit time you
can't even sit next to your loved one
the game's sit next to him not I mean
you and you can give them a hug when
they get there when they leave that's it
no kissing no nothing wow it's weird but
so there's no conjugal visits in federal
prison in the federal um it says
according to what I looked up it says
Trump who served as the chair of the
Trump media and Technology Group was one
of six members removed wait what's that
word chair chair uh yeah he was as the
chair of the Trump media and Technology
Group so he was a chair which what does
chair mean what does that mean what is
the meaning of that does that mean like
you're the head of something I mean you
might say like if there was like uh like
there was a table and there was a chair
right right you might feel like that's
the head of that table oh okay and so
okay you're in charge you know yeah
you're the one who lays out the
organizations ask these questions what's
wrong with us asking these questions
shouldn't we actually I got breaking
news folks I got breaking news there is
a conversation coming in from the White
House
apparently Donald Trump has called Joe
Biden he says up Hey Joe there's an
inaudible sound he said
Trump responds pardon me and dark brain
is nope
oh my God how many pardons is the next
president gonna have to commit to give
to Donald Trump right they keep doing
this [__] yeah they're like are you
gonna are you gonna commit to pardoning
Donald Trump like God damn that's all
you would be doing yeah like if you also
you guys are very obsessed with partying
a guy that like you know nothing wrong
for someone that you say you allege
right you believe that this guy just
like we say hey look there if there's
smoke there's fire this guy is a [__]
criminal and there are years and years
and years
of history of of showing his true self
but when you look at this guy and you
say oh no no this is just the Deep State
this is a Witch Hunt blah blah blah he's
innocent well if he's innocent why are
you gonna pardon him why does he need a
part of his innocence
Tony answer me the question why does he
need a pardon if he's innocent riddle me
this really asking questions that's
afraid of the big black Chris Christie
have you seen this with Chris Christie
no I know again this is pretty good also
also also also somebody uh they they
made a good point I I didn't I didn't
mention this uh Gottfried says to accept
a pardon you have to admit guilt well
that's the other problem that's the
other problem is that again when you're
handing out because he's gonna have a
lot of felony counts a lot of them like
a lot and to Pardon him of all those
felony counts
Godfrey's pointing out he's gonna have
to admit guilt of all those
felony counts I don't know
I'm just saying maybe I'm like my rocker
he said the stuff he he told people this
stuff like
he's gonna have to admit that there was
false so now he it wasn't bravado he was
actually he's not gonna get a party no
no he's not gonna do important he's not
gonna departed Chris Christie wouldn't
give him a pardon
Yeah well yeah and at a town hall Chris
Christie said he might consider it but
he basically said [__] no he said I'd
consider it if he was you know someone
Innocent but it doesn't look like he's
innocent so he can go [__] himself it's
kind of what Chris Christie which is a
big difference between him and Ron
DeSantis Rhonda Santos is like well next
question right like Trump I love Trump
he's so good I pretend to beat Trump for
years that's how I mean Chris Christie's
like look I've accepted the fact that I
might not win this but I will go down
right being outwardly spoken about this
guy Rhonda Santa's like look I don't
want to have to mention this guy's name
to keep it that kind of elusive and that
ambiguous that maybe you'll associate me
with him and say like I'm the Saving
Grace to get him out of his current
legal
[__] show right uh and I think that's a
I mean other than the fact that Ron
DeSantis is just like a fascist but uh
he's a Nazi yeah no no I mean I mean you
saw him yesterday right he said he was
going to get rid of all this I'm gonna
show the clip I'm gonna show the clip
how he's gonna smash up our institutions
that I don't know collect revenue for us
to do things like I don't know do
government and [__] I want a [__]
idiot um speaking of [__] idiots yeah
I think Chris Christie's a [__] idiot
I do I I really truly think Chris
Christie's a dumb [__] but at the same
time he's doing the country of service
by punching uh the the proverbial
punching bag of Donald Trump here the
best part about this he makes a lot of
good points especially at the end the
thing I loved about it most was that he
makes a cheeseburger Jeb see if you can
spot it when he [__] just punches him
in the [__] mouth with a cheeseburger
Jeb it's really funny because there was
a clip last week he played and someone's
like do you like it when Donald Trump
makes fun of you for being fat and
Christian is like [__] him he's fat too
yeah just like
well you know here it goes ears here's
Chris Christie see if you can spot the
the cheeseburger this is a pretty long
clip so I'm gonna play a lot of it
um because he keeps going but this is
the kind of punching we want to see on
the debate stage at the Republican
primaries because Chris Christie doesn't
just punch at Trump here he also punches
at DeSantis listen what he said to that
student
do you believe that Trump violated the
peaceful transfer of power a key
principle that of American democracy
that we must uphold are you in high
school
uh yeah so uh I wasn't anywhere near
Washington that doesn't [__] matter
what a weird one what happened that day
honestly I didn't enjoy seeing you know
what what happened but we've got to go
forward on this stuff we cannot be
looking backwards no no no no no no no
no no no no talked a little bit before
that about how Biden is running for
office and why he or Biden running and
why he should defeat him but is that the
way you think Republicans should be
answering that question on January the
6th he wasn't anywhere near Washington
did he have a TV
Was he alive that day
did he see what was going on I mean
that's one of the most ridiculous
answers I've heard in this race so far
you don't have an opinion about January
6th except to say I didn't particularly
enjoy
what happened
people were killed exactly a strong
statement people were killed Caitlyn as
you know that day on Capitol Hill
defending the capital
um we had members of Congress who were
running for their lives Joshua we had
people trying to hunt down the vice
president of the United States chanting
hang Mike Pence
outside outside the Oval Office that
little dining room of his eating a well
done cheeseburger
and watching TV and doing nothing to
stop what was going on until it got to
the point where even he could no longer
stand it and he finally had four
something in the afternoon put out a
video asking people to leave the capitol
okay did you spot it did you spot it
yeah jab I'm surprised he didn't say I'm
surprised he didn't say a well done
steak right ketchup that's what I always
say it's even that's what I would have
said no no no no no the cheeseburger is
even better man have you ever ate have
you ever ate a cheeseburger someone just
[__] cooked the [__] out of it yeah
it's [__] disgusting as [__] dry
nasty I mean you need a shitload of
ketchup whether you got it on the wall
or the floor on the burger you need a
shitload of ketchup whether it's then he
put ketchup on steak too that's what I'm
saying what the [__] I had people I made
fun of trump once I made a video where
people because everyone was like uh you
know you made a video once I made a
video once it was crazy uh it was on
that you should do that more often I
know I know I'm
and I got enough videos as it is I'm
trying to do them all I need a team of
people to [__] edit these videos for
me anyway
um
hey can someone can someone get down to
games yeah that would be great because
right now I do all of this stuff by
myself right I edit it yeah you got a
whole team interns over there that's
fine right you got them stuck in a
closet
um but when it comes to Donald Trump
there was a point where a lot of
Republicans were were like oh my God uh
Joe Biden is trying to take away our
meat you know there was like something
that there was [__] freaked out about
it was an actual thing and what ended up
happening was
I made fun of this fact that they were
getting super upset about like coming to
get their burgers or coming to get their
meat or whatever and this is my steak
out of my cold dead hands right yeah and
they're like and so what ended up
happening was I made a joke about this
guy who was at [__] Applebee's and he
was trying to order this burger and the
guy was like oh yeah we could do that
whatever and was making a big deal about
buying
and then he's like I want or he's like I
want a steak I want a well done steak
and I want it done like like President
Trump and I put ketchup on it and there
was a guy in the comments who's like oh
man this is so offensive Donald Trump
doesn't do that
and so and so then I did a follow-up
video where it was that guy
in the restaurant complaining to the
waiter and then the waiter being like no
here's the article that talks about him
having well done steaks with ketchup
okay so you go [__] yourself
you can go [__] yourself all the way up
now most people were like Tony why are
you talking about this cheeseburger line
in this listen I know
I know I want in any real timeline like
if we were in any sort of real reality
here Gabe uh Chris Christie would be the
front runner with this type of talk
right yeah it would happen that's if we
weren't in this [__] weird ass
alternate reality that we seem to be
living in but Chris Christie knows that
his little talk on January 6 is not
going to turn Trump voters to him right
what will is like Emma [__] eats
cheeseburgers well done and they're like
what are you kidding me like that guy's
like that's offensive I can't believe
he'd even say that Donald Trump eats
food like that I wouldn't support him if
he ate food like that like so Chris
Christie kind of understands this a
little bit right right and that's that's
why I thought that that cheeseburger jab
was just it was so subtle it felt like
it was little but it's like it's like
when you get hit in the nuts you know
someone's like Boop you're like oh
you're like that that kind of hit oh my
God and then you just Keel over like all
of a sudden it hits you you ever had
experience yeah I've been in the nuts a
few times it doesn't have to be hard to
just asked to make the connection right
uh the the other thing I want to point
out I mean yes it just has to make the
connection that's just like just a
little you're right it's just like
[__] even just a flip that's the
[__] worse
um but I love the fact that uh
that Rhonda santis totally irrelevant
doesn't even matter the first question
he asked back to the kid goes are you in
high school right yeah
who the [__] are you and are you in high
school why do you feel like you can ask
me that question I mean it was the same
same attitude right because it's totally
irrelevant you wouldn't ask someone are
you an adult are you in college are you
married do you have kids like I mean
unless it's something that pertains
specifically to the question that was
asked right you wouldn't have like hey
here's a question about Trump are you in
high school
irrelevant irrelevant and if anything it
shows you that if this kid is in high
school he is concerned about the
situation at hand which is and it also
ensures that Ron DeSantis didn't give a
[__] about him right and it's the same
attitude that you heard Ron DeSantis
when he went up to go do that little
[__] press conference and he's like
take off The Masks take off the mask I
hate [__] kids you bastards you
little bastards well I think Chris
Christie gets this because he's jabbing
at um uh Rhonda Santos here's but let's
listen to him finish up on uh on old
grandpa poopy pants he does a great job
really wadding him up throwing him in
the garbage so I want to show the rest
of the clip let's do it and Ron DeSantis
doesn't have any opinion on that
uh look I know by the way I'm pretty
sure I know who that high school student
was he goes to oh man town hall meeting
in New Hampshire three of mine and he
has to really watch this [__] Gabe and I
said to him the last time I found a
whole meeting he was out of mind see if
if any of the candidates will answer
your questions directly
um and grade them on it I suspect when I
go back and see Colin in uh in New
Hampshire next time I'm up there status
is going to get an F for that answer if
he asked you that question how would you
answer it I would say it was one of the
most okay he wouldn't he wouldn't answer
are you in high school Chris Gracie
knows this this dude's name yeah knows
his name Rhonda watch
watch watch what happens now everyone on
the right who supports Ron DeSantis and
or Donald Trump I can be like oh look
it's a [__] plant it's a Chris
Christie how is he related to Chris
Christie is this Chris Christie's son is
he is his nephew how does he know this
guy get the demateria encyclopedia out
they're like he's in high school so that
means he could be age from 14 to 18 so
if we do the math here and 7 and 1 1 7
17 Q Anon right it's 100 100 that's
what's going to turn out it is going to
be Chris Christie's long-lost nephew son
brother like oh we found out that it's
actually his illegitimate son right an
animal he was on the beach right exactly
and by the way he's a Fed 100 100 he's a
fan fed who also dresses up like the
people who were the Rose City Nationals
right and he goes to all these to these
Town Halls to ask Republicans questions
because he's just pretending to be a
republican he's not really one well
let's listen to how Chris Christie would
have answered Colin's question just
graceful days
in American history
and that the president was principally
responsible for it one through the
conduct and his words from election
night forward inciting people and
insisting that the election was stolen
when it wasn't
through his speech that day when he
attacked directly his own vice president
and incited those people to be angry at
Mike Pence who was just performing his
constitutional Duty and he had no choice
and every lawyer good lawyer had told
people that that he couldn't do anything
different than that and then while the
event was going on while the riot was
going on on Capitol Hill we know that
Donald Trump was watching it and was
being urged by even members of his own
family to get out there and say
something and he refused
because he was enjoying watching people
yell scream and Destroy things in his
name
um that's the kind of answer you should
give and that makes someone in addition
to all the other things unfit to be
president of the United States
so I I hate when
I have to to cheer on Chris Christie but
man keep [__] digging in because I
mean Chris Christie's at like five
percent I think
um so Rachel Dr Rachel bittickoffer
tweeted this video and then Caitlin
Collins posted on Twitter and this was
uh Rachel's response my donation my
donation to Chris Christie's campaign is
worth every time
I don't know if you've seen this RNC
rules but they have so many donations to
get on the stage yeah and and Democrats
are like let's [__] donate to Chris
Christie number one because he's just
not only he's gonna [__] with Trump
folks he's gonna [__] with the Santas
too yeah that's the important part Chris
Christie's not gonna win but he is going
to be a pain in the ass for Rhonda
Santos and Trump and if he gets on stage
the first time he won't be debating
Trump because Trump's not going to go to
the verse debate he's just not gonna do
it it's not in his Advantage it would
really it would be really stupid for him
to go on stage and get [__] up by
Chris Christie if Chris Christie makes
on stage because no doubt Chris Chris
Christie will [__] punch on him in
front of a live audience and the nation
just beat the holy living [__] out of
him Chris Christie's not scared of
Donald Trump it is clear he's one of the
only ones out there that isn't scared of
Donald Trump yeah I think it's because
she's one of the only ones don't have
[__] on and the other thing too is like
you know if you look back at comments
from Chris Christie like from January 6
it was you know the I think he's like uh
let's see I just want to pull this up so
we have a record of it he
um
he should be calling on law enforcement
to arrest those those people and
prosecute them to the fullest extent to
law yeah I think the president's conduct
today was simply incredible
as someone who has known it for 20 years
today uh today breached something none
of us could have put up with by anyone's
who's given who's been given the honor
of being elected a leader in this
country Christy one of the most
I am actually sickened by what I saw
today
um Christy also said that Trump violated
his oath and betrayed the American
people by not condemning those in the
mob who committed violence so he said it
from the beginning he said it from
January 6th he didn't interview he said
it from the beginning it said well he
was you know it's like oh like a Mitch
McConnell or Kev McCarthy kind of like
I'm swaying my uh my opinion right from
the very beginning he stuck with him so
here's the thing too about Chris because
Brenda brings up a good point here and
says sorry Tony uh I'll believe it when
I see it we'll see how well he stands up
to the orange blob now I'm not saying
Chris Christie's gonna take down Donald
Trump and then split MaGa on him all I'm
saying is is that people who aren't
staunch Maga who are going to make
decisions in the next election there has
to be clips that we have to run ads on
in the general election to convince
these people that would vote for Chris
Christie now because Chris Christie
won't be the nominee but if there's
footage of Chris Christie [__] just
banging his ass right wadding him up and
throwing him in the trash then we can
use those clips in the general election
to politicize and get people who would
vote for Chris Christie who are like
yeah that guy's way better than [__]
Trump he's got the same attitude but
he's not a dumb Buck if there's videos
of Chris Christie saying don't vote for
this [__] no one for this [__] it
makes people go to the polls and not
vote for Trump okay or trumpism Iran
DeSantis that's [__] important so
yeah I I I agree with you Brenda that
he's not going to throw the punches that
Chris Christie normally throws uh
because Chris Christie's trying to be
very calculated here on how not to ruin
his political career in the Republican
party uh whatever that may be after
Trump is gone
um but you know we still need them to
throw throw punches at each other
especially at this guy Ron DeSantis this
is that clip you're talking about Ronda
santis is like oh oh oh
you think Hitler was a fascist here hold
my beer listen this is [__] he's such
an idiot he's so [__] weird listen
are you in favor of of eliminating any
agencies I know conservatives in the
past have talked about closing the
Department of Education would you do
that
so we would do education we would do
Commerce we'd do energy and we would do
IRS and so if Congress will work with me
on doing that we'll be able to reduce
the scope of government even even the
Fox News I was like whoa whoa whoa wait
a second there champ yeah the IRS that's
what you want to do is get rid of the
IRS
the [__] out of here listen folks I
understand that the IRS seems like this
scary thing that intimidates most of
Americans it doesn't are you are you
telling me that the IRS won't kick down
my front door no not not only that not
only that the IRS doesn't give a [__]
about you if you don't make more than
five six seven hundred grand a year they
don't give a [__] about you they're not
gonna give a [__] about you okay they
don't have enough [__] manpower to
give a [__] about you number one the
people that they give a [__] about
are the Elite or the rich that's who
they give a [__] about why do you think
this scumbag wants to get rid of them
this scumbag wants to get rid of him
because him and all his [__] buddies
are the ones that the IRS give a [__]
about they don't give a [__] about
normal people They running around people
that have a [__] nine to five job
that barely make enough money to make
ends meet they ain't worried about you
even if you didn't pay your taxes for
three four five six years it's likely
that you have withholding and the
government owns owes you money okay on
most cases most cases in this country
because taxes are violent uh how you
file your taxes is voluntary right like
they don't there's no one standing at
your front door making you file your
taxes
tell me Tony right I know now again the
reason why these people don't like the
IRS is because the IRS want to hold
scumbags like Ron DeSantis and all his
[__] Rich buddies accountable but
let's listen to all the rest of the the
great ideas that the the Android in the
fascist skin suit has but what I'm also
going to do Martha is be prepared if
Congress won't go that far I'm going to
use those agencies to push back against
woke ideology and against the leftism
[Laughter]
let's let's go with the example of the
Department of Education let's hear it
meatball let's hear what pudding ideas
you get let's smoke this out the dumbest
[__] all the transgender sports stuff
women's sports should be protected
ah man let me tell you something let me
elect a president who's worried about
education and the only thing he can
focus on when it comes to the Department
of Education is genitalia what the [__]
are you talking about man it's work Tony
it's woke up the fact that they I mean
like you've got you've got Thomas Massey
you've got Lauren bobert they want to
abolish the Department of Education keep
in mind that Lauren bobert
okay is so incompetent
that she gave her own customers bloody
diarrhea yeah her own own restaurant
customer she [__] whipped up some
pork sliders I don't know if they were
unsanitary because of her alleged affair
with the former cook of Shooters Grill
TBD but what I can say is if you've got
someone wait wait back up wait a second
wait a second if you're saying that
something about this affair has to do
with these [__] these diarrhea
sliders I don't know man are you saying
that maybe they did they did some nasty
around the dude I am saying that that
look what I'm saying come on I'm telling
us what you mean yeah yeah I'm gonna
tell you what I mean I believe that
Lauren bobert and her former chef of
Shooters Grill which no longer exists
because the person who owns the building
was like no I'm not gonna [__] renew
your your [__] lease Oh I thought you
meant I thought you meant the former
cook no longer no no no no I'm just
saying I'm just saying the restaurant
right the restaurant is no longer there
you couldn't get a diarrhea slider even
if you wanted one look you could try
your hardest to give people [__]
diarrhea sliders and you probably
couldn't even succeed because you know
the human body is Pretty Tough we know
we we've done we've dealt with a lot but
I believe that Lauren Boberg yeah and
her former chef of Shooters Grill yeah
did something in the kitchen right then
they whipped up those sliders so so like
so like a secret sauce in the pork
sliders there might be something I'm
just saying I'm just saying unsanitary
this is allegedly right this is
allegedly yeah I'm gonna say it I'm
gonna say I'm gonna say full right full
right I mean alleged here alleged Affair
according to what they say but look at
if there's smoke there's fire right it's
all these [__] fake Christian women
that are in there that are in the GOP
they love to [__] project they're
[__] either pedophiles or their
predators or
there's somebody who you know has
Affairs and then they get divorced right
but I believe that they had some
unsanitary uh practices some encounters
in the kitchen and what ended up
happening was that spilled over to the
pork sliders and the pork sliders went
bad and she served up those pork sliders
to her customers and those people got
bloody [__] diarrhea ooh god well
then what does that mean she got then
an SDI oh okay well you know I have no
idea she got something what the [__]
does getting her into the Department of
Education it does nothing you're like
you're like can you imagine asking
someone you're like all right all right
so what you're saying
you the best idea you have is you want
to change the Department of Education
right and like yes you know like okay
wait right so what what do you why
removed well he said remove but if he
couldn't remove it he would make changes
right that's what he said yeah yeah so
and you're like okay all right Mr guy
who wants to be [__] prison you guys
have problems what are your suggestions
right Solutions right he's like dicks
dicks that's the problem just a big pile
of dicks I want to focus on genitalia in
the Department of Education like that's
all I can't focus on is dicks dicks dick
dick dicks like what why are you so it's
it's the Department of Education like
you're gonna try to educate the future
of our country give them the knowledge
educate them about the dicks Tony oh my
God I mean it goes straight for it too
didn't he he didn't like beat around the
bush or go over this roundabout radio
beat around the bush watch the language
right well you know all right beat
around the pubic hairs he didn't beat
around the pubic hairs to get around to
the whole transgender thing he just I
mean he went straight balls deep into it
oh yeah no he he went in there grabbing
grabbing as many as he could he was like
oh it's a grab bag gets a grab bag of
dicks we're just gonna talk about dicks
all day because that's exactly when you
think of the Department of Education
right some people might say oh well it's
the removal of parental rights
curriculum yeah curriculum it's the it's
the indoctrination of this curriculum on
to our students you know being in
schools and you know having to say the
Pledge of Allegiance I mean I mean maybe
about setting standards in public
schools no no the standards are dicks
right right and they and and you know
they're very very infatuated I bet you
if if Rhonda Santos or any of the
Republican people the Republican party
like lawmakers if they could have their
way they would spend their day their
whole [__] day going school to school
right they'd be like hey we gotta pass
this law he's like no no not until I see
the dicks
and they would go from school to school
to inspect because remember these in
some of these states they were like look
we're proposing these laws and you don't
actually have to have doctors or medical
professionals who are inspecting this
it's just someone on staff right it
could be some [__] creeper janitor
creeper for this teacher whoever that
they're the ones like yep I'm the person
that will facilitate the inspection of
the child's genitalia and Ron DeSantis
and all these other Republicans like no
no no no no let me get the first look
well Rhonda Sanchez is like look look I
eat pudding with three fingers so I'm
kind of an expert in this area yeah when
it comes to he's like well how big three
fingers deep like what it's like dude
right get your mind get telling you man
it is crazy but the fact that they want
to get rid of this stuff I mean I made a
joke yesterday was like no Agency for
you Nazi
I credited I credited you oh okay my
credit that's where I got the video from
uh
yeah
sometimes I retweet you
when I think they're halfway decent if
they're shitty um
you're like like I'm like that was all
right yeah like I'm like I've gave him a
little bit of a boost for a little bit
yeah like I like your [__] and then five
minutes later I'm like yeah
I really thought I thought about this I
thought about this for a while and I
know I now I know that I don't like that
speaking of not liking [__] oh
my God
now it's up to 40 million dollars yeah
dude it was five five ten fifteen twenty
it always reminds me actually I don't
know if we got to 15 20. it was 5 10 and
then I was like 440. well it always
reminds me of of [__] Austin Powers
when uh Dr Evil comes out and he's been
frozen for a long time for decades one
million dollars and they're like
one million dollars so that's nothing
and
yeah
they said uh because they they
what are they they're like our other
business alone makes like a couple
million or five million a year you know
and he's like oh oh okay uh a hundred
and they're like
yeah I did yeah if you're gonna if
you're gonna convince us that this is
real You're Gonna Want to do a little
bit more and Republicans start at like
five million dollars it must be like
five million bucks that ain't [__] yeah
what the [__] we're gonna I mean someone
sold [__] the Saudis for 2 billion with
a b and you're worried about five
million bucks get the [__] out of here
man that's that's just another day on
Capitol Hill okay yeah just another
[__] day on Capitol Hill five million
bucks so then they're like okay
Timmy how's that sound ten and
everyone's like nah it's that still
sounds like a load of [__] yeah now
they're up to 40 million dollars they're
up to 40 million dollars here on Fox
News how are they getting up to 40
million dollars if they don't have any
evidence I'll tell you they're making it
up oh it's all [__] so I don't know
telling me why it's [__] what's
funny about this what's funny about this
is Ducey ask Jim Comer he's like make it
easy for us like literally he's like
look what you're saying makes no sense
at all try to give it to us
in a way that we can understand your
lies because he has been remotely
interviewed recently and they said do
you have evidence and and Ducey was like
sounds like you don't have any evidence
right that's like he's all a bunch of
[__] it's not what I said he goes it
sounds like you don't have any evidence
which I'm like again
fox is like [__] man uh we got a we
gotta fact check these the reason why
Fox is so [__] tiptoe about this is
because they um they got their asses
shoot off from Dominion yeah and this
isn't they're just getting their asses
right this isn't just them disparaging
and defaming a president United States
which I don't know if people know this
you can't defame a public official
that's not a that's not a I mean you can
but not based on their policies right
like yeah they're coming out so I can
say whatever I want about whoever I want
that's a that's a public servant well
not exactly but but defamation and
there's you can't can't just you can't
just fling stuff at people but if you're
a public servant or you're a public
figure it's really hard to define a
defamation that's why I said if I said
James Comer right is a Russian plant
that's not defamation because he because
he's because he's a publicly now James
Comer's brother if you accuse him of
being a Russian plant and have no
evidence whatsoever because he's not a
public figure right yeah but you're
trying to use it to make paint change
Comer as a Russian asset which he
probably is but if you you if you said
Bill Bill Comer yeah and I don't know if
his brother's bill but Bill Comer if his
bro his brother and you make up all
kinds of lies and he's taking money from
China at first his five million is ten
is 40 million he totally is taking money
from China Russia God knows who else
that bill Comer is a piece of [__] that
[__] he's definitely in bed and
I would bet that bill Comer gave all
that money to James Gomer just to say
disparaging stuff about Hunter and Joe
Biden if you said stuff like that yeah
right that would be defamation to Bill
Comer because he's not a public figure
see so that's why they fox has to be
really careful about the Biden family
right that's why we don't have to be
careful about Jared Ivanka they were in
the administration I don't know yeah
yeah they were they were there you know
they didn't really have a job but
Kimberly Guilfoyle Eric Trump uh Laura
Trump they're all part of campaign
they're all part of the campaign
official parts of the campaign they're
public figures they're public figures so
you people really need to learn what
defamation is but here's here's James
cummer and Fox News trying to manage
these lies about and this defamation
about the Biden family and try to see if
you can follow Gabe exactly what it is
that the bidens did
I am having trouble with it but let's
see let's see if if James Comer can make
it easy on the Fox News host here so
make it easy for us what was the crime
well the crime is uh Trading policy for
for money which policy well we're going
to get into that I mean look Joe Biden
has on day one he changed our energy
policy in America yeah he's the
president put China first in America
last night ended the China initiative
which was an investigation at all our
public universities of a very organized
Chinese spy ring where China was sending
students to universities to steal our
research and development so you're
saying because members of the bun uh the
100 Biden family and the extended Joe
Biden family got money through various
foreign entities including things like
things from China that the president is
compromised absolutely
did you did you catch any of that [__]
okay okay okay okay okay I think I got
it okay so there's this wait wait wait
wait see if see if you can make it
easier than what James comey's uh
as soon as I hadn't seen this clip yep
oh you haven't I hadn't seen that clip
okay and the first thing that came to my
mind yep was Michael Scott in the office
and he's like
okay
explain it to me like I'm a
five-year-old
and that's the first thing that I
thought of and I will probably end up
doing what was that on this anyway so
when I heard this he's like so there's a
Chinese spa ring okay and that Chinese
spy ring is working with the with the
buttons and the buy-ins are working with
higher education institutions you know
those very ones that the Supreme Court
just are those the woke ones are those
the woke ones yeah the very ones okay
okay and they're all doing [__] crack
and uh
and it doesn't I like I'm I'm trying
like okay so there's a Chinese spy ring
and then there are these other people
and then there's the bidens and then
and then I'm I'm like I'm still trying
to there's a missing bridge between like
this part of the the town and this part
of the town and I and I don't know I
haven't been able to build and cross the
bridge at the same time and I think
that's what they're they're trying to
like build the car
at the same time they're driving it
because they're like oh so you have it
it's like well that's what we're looking
into right oh well that and then and
then at the end is like so he's a
criminal like yeah absolutely yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you you have evidence
well oh no no no no no no no no no no no
no no we are
I mean I mean the United States Attorney
in Delaware that Trump appointed to make
sure to put Joe Biden and Hunter Biden
in jail he did an extensive
investigation and actually Hunter Biden
it turns out he didn't pay his tax like
he should so he paid him back and they
still made him plea to misdemeanor
charges for not paying his taxes and
they gave him [__] gun charge so
they did that they did
they did that we we got him [__] got
him but also well I I got some I got
some breaking news oh hit it do it this
is uh um let me see if I can pull this
up here now let me take that down I
don't want to look at them uh I want to
pull this in it looks like um outside
the Supreme Court
[Music]
oh you want you want to play this yeah
well I had to okay so so this was coming
from the U.S uh Capitol Police
um here that looks like a it says 47
minutes ago said we're assisting um the
Supreme Court police with a suspicious
package out of abundance of caution
we're also helping uh keep the area
clear we cannot provide further
information about other agencies case
but we will keep the community updated
about our involvement
um they also say road closed they give
the road closures here so they're
closing down roads because of a
suspicious package uh we should
definitely send Republicans in if
there's a suspicious package my question
is where is Marge where's Marge where's
Marge where is anyone has anyone looked
at a at a pipe facility or anyone lately
you know what I'm gonna actually
um has anyone seen Marge I'm just yeah
that seemed like a good question to
quote tweet that one on I mean I'm just
Hey look
I can't say for certain but I'm just
asking questions you know about where
the exact location of Marjorie Taylor
green is someone say some say pipe
bomber some say peep bomber I don't know
potato potato right Sleater slider
diarrhea Slater diary the slider I don't
I don't know you know this is all stuff
that you can go on okay so we got a few
more minutes and I I gave uh a 30 minute
rant on the yeah speaking of this I'm
gonna go out on a limb here and say it's
either it could be nothing right uh but
I also
do not think that it would be so like
the decision came down right today of of
uh affirmative action right yes well I
wanted to say I did 30 minutes so I want
to give you a chance yeah you got a few
minutes left to talk about what your
opinion is on the firm and so the thing
that I uh the thing that I I see here is
like I I would hope I would hope that
someone who is upset with this you know
with this uh decision wouldn't take such
an action and I don't believe that
anyone would it doesn't make a lot of
sense that you would threaten to leave a
sisters package or bomb after a decision
has been made right it's not like you're
trying to solve or or fix anything
that's already been decided now what I
do think I do think that it's could be
if it is something or was was done
intentionally right uh
was by the result of someone on the
right you know I'm gonna go on a limb
and say it is now I don't know like was
a package it was sent in it was mailed
which means if that's the case and it
had to be done before this it was
dropped off like I I don't know it
doesn't doesn't make a lot of sense for
someone on the left to go about
doing that right
but that's just me having if the
suspicious package turns out to be
something more than just suspicious but
give us tell me because you are a
Hispanic descent yeah okay not only is
Hispanic descent you have a Hispanic
name we know Seb Gorka likes to point
that out yeah
so tell me about your your feelings
because
um you you would have experienced I I'd
have no experience in this area I'm I'm
a white pasty cracker I'm a whiter than
a Saltine
um I don't have
um that experience in my life but you do
so coming from someone who has this
experience when you heard the news this
morning and not only that reading
reading the actual decision from someone
like Clarence Thomas
um who benefited from affirmative action
and now is blocking the ability for
people Clarence Thomas is he's
definitely got his [__] heel on
everyone's head right like he made it
out of the quicksand and everyone's like
oh [__] like help me help me because we
know that our society and in other
places as well around the world but in
our in our society in the U.S
uh
we we have a broken system in many
different ways right in in our society
and our in our socioeconomic status in
our education and obviously those are
things that would help Advance us
forward would have put us on some kind
of equal footing right and Clarence
Thomas is someone who benefited from
those things got out of the quicksand
and then stuck his [__] heel
and everyone else's [__] head to push
them back down right or like there was a
stick and he just took the stick and he
[__] tossed it out right or the Rope
or whatever kind of analogy you want on
that but I look at that and Clarence
Thomas really is someone who who
benefited from those things looked back
and said you guys no no you guys are not
gonna live this life that I have I have
worked too damn hard and benefit from
from the benefited from this system to
have these million dollar vacations from
people like Harlan Hitler that none of
you guys are gonna none of you guys are
gonna get this either no no no no you're
not gonna get this [__]
and the way that I look at this
is someone who is from the Latino
community
having a diverse representation
in this example let's just apply it to
higher education right having this so
that you can actually have access to
higher education that puts you in
another level right puts you in
competition with other candidates at a
job to say I have the education I have
the experience I have the schooling I
have the knowledge that I can also be as
good if not better than that other
person that's not like me right
and I also look at this as a slippery
slope
because you look at affirmative action
you say oh well first it's just based on
race right it's just based on race and
we want to make sure that it's all
merit-based
which just makes it easier for someone
in the admissions office to go well that
name sounds bruty ethnic
nope not to you ah this guy John uh
Smith sounds pretty stand up to me if
you ask me you know like I I that's the
way I'm gonna put it and so I look at
this and I say it starts with race just
like it starts with Roe v Wade guys it
was just abortion it was just abortion
we just wanted to make sure that women
were getting these abortions and killing
these babies
and then you see it begins to slide into
these other areas right something that
you might be like oh that's too
far-fetched that's Hyperbole and then
you look six months nine months one year
after Roe v Wade and you go oh
okay turns out that these people that
were [__] waving the flag and sending
up [__] flare guns were actually
right
it wasn't just hyperbole it wasn't just
like one thing it wasn't just Roe v wave
guys and abortion it was much more than
that and I look at the way
in which this comes down and I see this
is the same thing because look you have
affirmative action affecting just people
of their race when they apply to school
but what's to impact women
right what's to impact someone
presenting and say oh well I wanna I
wanna now put this in the workplace and
say that I don't have to hire people
because of their race I don't want to
have to hire people because they're
women right I don't have to uh
invite them or admit them into my school
because you know male versus female
right I can all just put up this blanket
excuse of it was merit-based it was
merit-based right and that's a tough
thing to like
to argue and I mean I could see a lot of
like lawsuits that come into this but I
see this as just one step into like
breaking down the door of all of these
other things that they want to come
after right it starts with higher
education it starts with race it bleeds
into the workplace it bleeds into other
genders right it's not just one thing
it's never just one thing you've got uh
you've got Clarence Thomas who during
the decision of Roe v Wade even
throughout the possibility of same-sex
marriage or into racial marriage
this isn't just one thing it's never
just oh we're going after this one thing
and that's it guys and then you know
what cool we can go [__] golf no no
they're planning many many moves ahead
if this moves if this Domino Falls then
this one will fall then this one will
fall and this one will fall right
and we saw that with Roe v Wade
I believe we're gonna see it with
with affirmative action right it's just
it takes one [__] crack
for them to move on to the next thing
and say ah great okay this is
tangentially connected we'll find some
legal case to make this work and we'll
remove those rights from those people
and we'll remove those rights from those
people and those rights and those rights
and so when people say oh whoa go you're
being hyperbole it's it's not fascist
somebody when I tweeted yesterday for an
example I said no Agency for you Nazi
right and somebody commented or quote
tweeted and said
this is all you leftists do all you say
is Nazi for anyone that disagrees with
you and no I look I I'll call you an
[__] or a [__] head or a bigot or
whatever but when I use the word nazer
when I call when I talk about fascism
I'm literally talking about you removing
the rights of people you saying oh
there's only one race there's only one
gender there's only one way that you
should appear and look and say and talk
and believe in practice and whatever it
is
and those are the people that are trying
to take those things away from us right
well in that example with the Department
of Education if if Ron DeSantis would
have his way and get rid of the
Department of Education one Fell Swoop
do you think white rich children
wouldn't get educated
no they'd be educated they'd be a rich
white children just like just like rich
white men are able to still find an
abortion for their mistress that's right
right you're it's gonna happen they're
gonna find a way to [__] wiggle their
way through their because they're all
[__] snakes you're right it's not
about and it's not about the educate
Rhonda Santos isn't saying I want to
abolish Department of Education because
education bad he's saying I don't want
to educate people that aren't White
rich white people that's what I don't I
don't want I don't want to educate them
I don't want to educate them right the
same way that they're saying because the
analogy with the quicksand you said
right is is [__] fantastic he got out
of quicksand and then he put his [__]
he's turned around and put his [__]
heel on the people that are left in the
quicksand to push him down I mean
they've agreed and like even on the
education side right it's like they're
already doing it and they're already
successful and keeping their
constituents dumb and believing the
thing that they say right there's no
fact check there's never any question
there's never any doubt it's always like
they wouldn't lie to me they're telling
me the truth which is always what
they're doing but on top of that right
just look at [__] new college in
Florida that's another example of
someone like Rhonda santis trying to
change the way in which higher education
uh is structured and also is is
administered by changing the board of
directors and now making this place that
was very good probably subpar in a
couple years because like oh we got to
bring in all these other people we got
to make it fair
no you want more white people in and
you're trying to take these
opportunities away from someone
who normally wouldn't have it and now
you're ensuring that they definitely
won't have it which is their that's
exactly their aim that's exactly their
aim and we'll stay on top of them here
at the Tony Michaels podcast don't
forget don't forget to subscribe to the
YouTube channel today's Thursday it's
gonna be bonehead of the week tomorrow
so you get the vote on YouTube Here's
what happens here's what happens Gabe
Sanchez I'll normally here in the this
evening the moderators remind us hey you
boneheads put up the bonehead poll and
then Gabe Sanchez goes over to Twitter
and puts it at Tony Michael's potty
he'll put up the bonehead pulled there
you can vote there and then I put it up
on the YouTube channel so those are the
two places you'll be able to vote for
bone net of the week you vote you decide
who is the bonehead of the week and then
tomorrow on Friday we break it down for
you in the second hour now also this
afternoon you have the opportunity to
download this episode which you should
on Apple Spotify Google it's so
important that you download the audio
version that helps us out a lot here at
the show but if you miss it on YouTube
if you don't watch it and you don't
listen to it another place you can watch
it Gabe Sanchez is Facebook at the Tony
Michaels you can watch this on Facebook
if you still have a Facebook account you
can watch it there or you can watch it
on Twitch you can follow us on Twitch
for free it's free99 files on Twitch
but if you want to give us some extra
dollars for free on Twitch here's what
you do
you go to the Tony michaels.com you
click the link it's the fourth one down
it says link your Amazon account to your
Twitch account
the directions are right there it's
really simple a great moderator the
mighty librarian put the directions
together it and all you do is link the
two together give us the one free
subscription you get with Amazon gaming
with your Prime account and we get a
couple bucks each month and you got to
renew it and she did something new here
Gabe she put the directions on how to
renew and resubscribe on so even if
you've done it and you forgot how to do
it you can go right to the
tonymichaels.com click on that link it
gives you the description and all the
directions on how to subscribe how to
link the two and how to re-subscribe to
the Tony Michaels podcast actually
actually yeah actually so it we're
almost through the end of June which is
we're almost through pride month right
uh and there was one
um I think it was Stargell 46 she asked
if if we don't already have it uh can we
add a light blue I think is what is what
she was asking if we can add a light
blue option
for the [__] em Pride shirt well I did
the options that I have are the options
that I have unfortunately so those are
the options with the supplier that we
have I wish I could get different colors
but I can only select so many and we
only get out of so many so I'm I
apologize but hey you know what that
gives me a good cue into this yeah we
only have a few days left and we got
that promo code out there for Pride if
you go to store not the Tony
michaels.com That's stored.d Tony
michaels.com use the promo code Pride
that's promo code pride and you get 15
off all your entire purchase there this
the the merch store so go to
store.the20michaels.com we got a few
more days left of pride month that you
can get your pride merch there at the
merch store
what a show what a disappointment today
with this decision from the Supreme
Court it really is them yeah we started
the week we're like oh hey look
understandably uh or predictably so we
knew who was going to vote against it in
terms of uh you know voting rights
um it was a good decision and that was a
good thing it went our way right right
but then well the same the same decision
with the Ohio State wrestling great
decision great decision and then we had
a couple decisions this week that
weren't so great and now when do they go
out on recess for the summer tomorrow
today aren't they always on right I
don't know I don't know I mean Thomas
Clarence Thomas is definitely leaving on
a luxurious vacation oh yeah he's
definitely gonna go hang out with Harlan
for sure for sure it's show for show you
know what else is for sure you know what
else is for sure same time same place
tomorrow
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em [__]
[__] them
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon
listen to it
1776 he said
he didn't see it you can't see a
recording 1776 you can only listen to
recording
you curtains
1776 that has done more damage to this
country
the uranium one five six 1776 she had a
server that was illegal
tsscisap classified information on it
1776 that U.S officials have said is
absolutely hackable by nation state
1776 including Russia I really really
think that this woman needs to get off
social media 1776 get off Twitter and
find a lawyer
who's better than the lawyer she used
1776 to buy that Russian Russian
propaganda to get that illegal
surveillance warrant against 1776.
you have to laugh because otherwise you
get really really angry
foreign